321 em um ato sexual de quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos é mais um
vídeo e um estrado chique finais é
fredes 3 não com quatro estamos aqui
para jogar a quarta noite como vocês
tanto pedem não sei o que meu vocês
devem comer faz nights o pequeno almoço
não saiu do mar a poeira segundo itaipu
jorge samek pec 4 com medo para que os
quatro não sei o que fazer sem jogar sem
parar não sei mas pronto vamos rasgar
muito quatro finais entregues quatro
horas lá ok estamos no nosso quarto e
vocês têm que mudar um descontinho desta
vez não é porque já não joga está muito
tempo ouviu foxy já que eu acho que vai
aumentar um pouco o volume não consigo
ver bem as coisas se eu for aumentar o
volume do jogo já não vai abrir porque
está tudo trabalha aqui consegue sair do
banho com a água precisava o trato como
mil duro jato suado e já não saiu como
segura o filho e vocês querem que eu
faça o favor né diz frases como só pra
passar a noite 13 14 e perdeu um rim e
vão surgindo e querem baixar 84 isso tem
de vir até a 10ª noite já não side of
prática chica trabalhadores agora o foco
será que o bicho demônio vai te embora
eu duvide esfregar sabonete no chão
transportaram e à frente eu acho que não
vou ter que ficar aqui alguém fecha a
porta a porta
agora vim agora consegui ouvir eu
preciso me concentrar com o povo não tá
baixo e eu não consiga aumentar o volume
outra vez porque se aumentar o volume o
jogo foi cheio começa a travar tudo eo
vídeo foi com os porcos e ela tá aqui ó
ela não erro fox é um homem né se bem
que o foco se é raposa é a raposa não é
um raposa mas pronto o o hotel e aí não
possa ser hoje sinto uma pressão pessoal
sinto uma pressão comigo se eu fosse uma
panela era uma panela de opção e fazia a
roja toda hora que eu saiba o new born o
fox um dos dois de comerem cível
a etec chica nené país chapa não haverá
mais rápido rápido rápido sabe isso o
povo está aqui ok muita concentração e
não se possa ascender hoje
valeu fox rock in rio não conseguiram no
entanto tenho dinheiro à frente ao
casino também é favorita aqui o destaque
foi a por telefone o planeta que já
aceitaram filha da mãe do cubano coc
apps americana precisa que o bolo e
vamos ver a importância de que não vai
prorrogar em ataques em primeiro
afinal não o final méxico a mexicana
chicão estava mal prata esta hora
precisa ter calma agora precisa que a
marca americana já tinha três bichos do
magnate aqui
ae é o boni fox international a cair uma
da manhã já vamos conseguir encontrar a
não sair alguém entrou já tá já entraram
aqui mesmo já entraram aqui baixar faixa
que já sei que vai passar daqui pra nos
estados
ae a yamaha a yamaha aí quer matar uma
menina na cama mas não é muita pressão é
eu vou morrer aqui algum barulho que não
parece o cara e vou estar tranquilo
são duas na minha pessoal são duas da
manhã eo meu sangue já a primeira linha
que já estava honrada jato suava já não
sei que aqui se sentir mais é preciso o
mario garoto anda boa a nossa porta está
tudo bem tudo bem aqui o blog e agora é
calminho levar a tomar calmante
cumprindo índia
não sei se foi o irã eo iraque mas
pronto pelo menos tentei e é alguém da
minha canon é e ainda ganha que eu sei
que o fox está pronto para aceitar
alguém na porta né votar aqui né ai ai
que eu fosse ficar aqui por um tempo a
sair né anos quando começa a buscar esse
emocional precisa captar mais rápido do
mundo outra vez meu como é que é
possível o burro se recusem a tão rápido
eu não vim para ficar muito tempo sem
jogar mas é fredes na época agora já não
consigo chegar já previa que a linha
habilitada ataque e o apito fax comprar
umas maia já fazem barulho do pata
consigo sentir o sabor do
o suor e brutus correr está tudo escuro
e pra minha cara eu divido entre o jô
eu foco se um fosse nada eo que chama um
fred eu freei isso mesmo fred e saltou
da cama que esse vírus moniz é isso
temos que servir as coisas não vai dar o
pessoal não vai dar não vai dar para
passar esta noite ele não vai acabar
pessoal e leste agora lá meia noite
ainda claro começa sempre pela manhã
então vamos começar a se afastar mas não
é meu herói
está tudo tranqüilo é um dever
eu acho que se eu cantar eu vou fugir em
tarô eletrônicos por isso eu vou tentar
cantar um pouco falei demônio não fica
na carne é tao bem na porta
eu não sei eu sei isso não é na outra é
na outra porta eu acho que já entraram
dentro do primário está aqui alguém e
chica é chica fazer um bo que a porta eu
acho que ela faz o golo que após o jogo
entra porque um boom com o sacristão
rápida cozinha aqui por quarto é eu não
sei se os bulls têm vida mas o bumbo e o
disco bolo estava na porta é chica faço
gol à minha porta e um cabelo parece que
o sol queima no topo o sol não é isso
que estou a lâmpada do destino tá ok vou
parar vou parar de ser estúpido é parar
de jogar porque eu ainda vou tentar mais
mais três vezes eu não sei eu não sei se
vou conseguir aguentar aqui muito tempo
jogar isto mas eu vou tentar pelo menos
baixo até às quatro da manhã
vamos ver só para cortar e tem umas
batatas anão que o pet um bobo e escova
tatus qual cage objecções tesouras e não
sai pessoal eu não sei se eu vou falar
mais ou se ficar um creme gelado e
concentrado né
eu acho que é melhor ficar calado disse
o ala
estou me concentrar e fazer um palanque
aqui na câmara que você parece muito
rápido tem estado atenta que a cama eu
tentar muito mais atenta à cama do que
qualquer outra coisa
haja preciso cada vez que vejo uma porta
eu tenho de ver a casa com água cargo
faz bem à saúde é mesmo quando você leva
um susto e logo é bom tanto cansado de
jogar isto porque não ba
o peru que eu tenho tudo pra passar uma
faca em noite uma uma noite perto 20
horas de quixadá minha pele invés por
seu filho mais velho que está no grid é
muito stress aqui como ano
eu vou ter alguns buscam ai meu deus no
e se a ok mas que será citada lei
então é isso ao buscar porque com este
vírus para que vocês tenham gostado
apesar de não ter passado a 4ª noite não
é mas eu vou tentar passar se vocês
quiserem ver mais claro deixa eu vou
falar em favorito muito obrigado por
tudo o que fazemos tem dado está a ser
mesmo o samba vocês não mostram por
passeios que kun não saiu fiquei sem
palavras com o amor que vocês mudam se
eu conquistar um bairro cada um de vocês
eu juro que eu dava mas como eu não sou
gay não é só mudar as minhas raízes
pessoal fique bem light favorito e já
muda
[Música]